пане президенте колеги власне працюючи
багато років зі служби безпеки України в
звільненні заручників я точно знаю що
там є і Герої і зрадники І власне Ми
вітаємо той факт що сьогодні Служба
безпеки України говорить про те що треба
зосередитися на боротьбі за зрадниками
попередник пана малюка був звільнений з
дуже жорстким формуванням за дії
наслідками яких стали важкі втрати І
власне той попит на справедливість який
є сьогодні в суспільстві Він чекає
розслідування і оцінки А які ж це були
дії і до яких наслідків вони привели це
дуже важливо Ми вітаємо подачу заявки до
НАТО це також дуже важливо і наша
солдати сьогодні роблять це для того щоб
Україна стала членом Альянсу треба
тільки повернути доплати в армію це дуже
серйозні сигнали тому що військові мають
отримувати гідні зарплати це наші
ключове питання а от що стосується
нашого домашнього завдання то маємо
інформувати Службу Безпеки щоб дійсно
вона займалася контррозвідкою і захистом
територіальної цілісності України і в
цьому питанні є два шляхи або
контррозвідка буде Ну дійсно ключовим
Службі безпеки або це буде монстр щодо
політичних репресій І от зараз час
закрити всі ці політичні справи які й
досі там в недрах дбр СБУ є про Томас
про Контрнаступ 14-му році про
керченську протоку Це буде дуже
правильний сигнал
щодо єдності Ми думаємо що маємо
підтримати службо безпеки України в
боротьбі з п'ятою колоною давайте
приймемо в цій залі і наша фракція тут
буде ініціатором закони які забороняють
ліквідовують цю Московську церкву і ми
вітаємо заборону про московських партій
це дуже правильно тільки депутати її
знаходяться і в сесійній залі і в
місцевих радах також давайте цим щось
зробимо тому що насправді поки солдати
захищають нашу Батьківщину на фронті Ми
так само маємо все зробити для захисту
України в тилу і тут